Киянин Олександр Чапко став футбольним уболівальником 34 роки тому.
Протест РФ проти зображення карти України з Кримом на формі збірної, як і протест проти написів "Слава Україні! Героям слава!"
він вважає, як мінімум, нелогічним.
Адже вітання "Слава Україні!" має історичне походження.
Воно використовувалося в Українській Народній Республіці в 1918 році.
А от привітання у відповідь - "Героям слава!" - ввели в обіг члени ОУН і УПА за часів Другої світової війни.
В сучасній Україні привітання стали активно використовувати під час Євромайдану і з моменту анексії Криму та війни на Донбасі.
Уже третій рік воно є офіційним привітанням в українській армії та поліції.
На даний момент вітання "Героям слава!" більшість українців асоціює не зі Степаном Бандерою
та іншими постатями часів Другої світової війни, а з захисниками України на Донбасі.
Слава Україні! Героям слава!
Для мене це не просто вислів. Це такий само символ нашої духовності і культури, як наш герб , прапор.
Якщо пам'ятаєте, на гербі СРСР під червоної зіркою була ціла земна куля,
і тоді ані в УЄФА, ані в кого іншого питання не виникало, чому цей с символ покриває всю територію.
Тому я вважаю, що нісенітниця.
І я би сказав, що це забаганки тих, кому не подобається Україна, як незалежна держава.
Дизайн форми української збірної УЄФА затвердила ще в грудні 2020-го.
Протест РФ проти зображення на карті України Криму і слів вітання на формі української збірної
викликав хвилю обурення серед українців.
В Україні не згодні і з  рішенням УЄФА все-таки прибрати з форми частина вітання "Героям слава!"
Навіщо? Який сенс це робити, якщо це гасло тут прийнятне і всі до цього нормально ставляться.
Я вважаю, що вони до такого не дійдуть.
Вони не можуть суперечити якійсь єдиній європейській політиці щодо України.
Це ж європейська організація. Я вважаю, вони можуть бути тільки за, а не проти.
Якщо це призведе до міжнародного конфлікту, то, мабуть,
треба прислухатися, хоча це і не буде приємно країні.
Але, якщо це чисто вимога Росії або недекларовані якісь вимоги, це зайве, можна залишити символіку, як є.
Звісно, не прибирати. Чому ми повинні це прибирати?!
Для мене ніякої різниці. Але… Спорт і ці написи  - це не сумісне!
Це тільки всередині написано? І іх це турбує?
Я думаю, треба  відстоювати свою позицію. Тим паче, що це зворотня сторона футболки.
І привітання також до міжнародної спільноти і привертання також до міжнародної спільноти. В нас все ж таки війна.
Чого ми маємо це прибирати?
Треба відстоювати свою позицію
Негативно. А чому не можна? Це ж український  символ "Героям слава." Україна без цього не може бути.
Я думаю, треба йти до суду і побачимо,  що буде.
Україна не погоджується з рішенням УЄФА про зміну дизайну форми.
Більше того, вислови "Слава Україні! Героям слава!", Герб і карту України з усіма тимчасово окупованими територіями
вирішено зробити офіційними футбольними символами України.
Вболівальник Олександр Чапко впевнений, що ця форма увійде в історію спорту, як унікальна.
Ще до суперечки в УЄФА її швидко розкуповували в магазинах спонсора збірної.
Тепер, каже Олександр, тим більше. Хоча ціну цієї футболки в майже 60 євро він вважає дещо завищеною.
Шеф української команди Андрій Шевченко на гучну критику росіян не зважає:
Мене цікавить наша реакція, наших вболівальників. Я думаю, нашим вболівальникам форма сподобалася. Тому я задоволений.
Форма була затверджена УЄФА , тому я не бачу тут ніякої суперечки, сontroversy, як Ви сказали.
Рішення УЄФА в тій же Німеччині сприймають по-різному.
Експерт зі спортивного права Райнер Шерке заявив DW, що "на тлі кримського конфлікту дизайн української форми
можна розглядати як предмет устаткування із політичним змістом, що заборонено правилами УЄФА".
Оглядач німецького футбольного видання Kicker Мартін Ґрюнер назвав дизайн форми "шпильками" з боку України
у бік Росії, хоча, на його думку, обриси країни використовувати "абсолютно легітимно
відповідно до міжнародного права".
Мене не здивувало те, що Росія відреагувала одразу.
Я здивований радше тим, що Україна зробила цей, так би мовити, укол шпилькою.
З точки зору міжнародного права, якщо я не помиляюсь, відображати обриси країни є легітимним.
Інше запитання – чи потрібно було це робити? Чи вартувало привносити у спорт цей політичний рівень?
Як УЄФА вирішить, так і буде. УЄФА, як і ФІФА, так само як і МОК, вимагають, аби жодні політичні месиджі не виставлялися напоказ на футболках.
В цьому сенсі, вочевидь, карта, обриси країни розглядаються не як політичний месидж, а як реальність.
Американські дипломати в Києві взагалі приміряли форму збірної України з футболу
та презентували фото про це з написом, що, мовляв, з нетерпінням чекають першої гри,
і що українська команда виглядатиме чудово.
Вболівальник Олександр Чапко сподівається, і що гарячі дискусії та суперечки не завадять грі збірної.
Я думаю, що нам головне думати про результат ЄВРО.
Я думаю, ця футболка не тільки залишиться в мені в пам’яті.
Але і тим, що вона унікальна. Такої більше ні у кого не буде!
То в якій же формі вийдуть українські гравці на поле в своєму першому матчі Євро-2020 13 червня?
Це питання і у день відкриття чемпіонату Європи відкрите.
Але українські вболівальники і пересічні громадяни вірять у те, що суперечки навколо дизайну
не стануть приводом для з'ясування стосунків між затятими фанатами української та російської збірних.